Je dois commencer par le fait que j'étais
un garçon, j'étais un garçon naïf de Cicinho qui
ne comprenait pas la gravité dans laquelle j'étais,
vous savez quand j'ai entendu le juge dire que
vous serez en prison pendant 30 ans à
perpétuité plus la vie vous  savez que vous êtes un enfant,
vous ne pouvez même pas comprendre ce qu'ils
ne voulaient pas dire simplement travailler sur une baie comme une
semaine ou un mois,
il ne peut même pas prévoir une année dans votre
vie à cet âge, mais finalement quand je  je
vous ai appris que l'institution qui y
était détenue est devenue très réelle à
ce moment-là,
heureusement pour moi, j'ai réalisé que je
ne pouvais pas accepter cela, je ne pouvais pas simplement
m'asseoir et dire bon c'est ça c'est
la fin de mon histoire  et donc j'ai commencé à
me défendre
[Music]
la preuve utilisée pour me condamner était un
témoin de nuit qui a témoigné qu'ils
m'avaient vu commettre le crime et la façon
dont cela s'est produit était qu'ils montraient une
programmation photographique et ce n'était que six
photos et  on a demandé au témoin
de choisir l'une des photographies et c'est ce qu'il a
fait et cela a été arrêté pour cela
tu sais heureux non pas de pouvoir de dire non je
ne veux pas jouer le jeu ou tu ne
sais pas d'influence sur sa propre vie pour dire
comme si je n'avais rien dit
à la place il faisait juste ce qu'ils
voulaient qu'il fasse et donc je  Je l'ai rencontré
lui et moi Scott Turner lui et moi
ne sommes pas les meilleurs amis du monde, mais
vous savez que nous pourrions déjeuner de
temps en temps et vous savez que je pense qu'il n'est
aussi qu'une des victimes qui
profitait de  autre système
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Applaudissements] [
Applaudissements]
[Musique]
La plus grande surprise pour
moi dans mon histoire et/ou dans les histoires que j'ai
réalisées sur Frankie était que le
grand public  moi-même avons inclus tous ceux qui
ont grandi dans des livres de films sur des histoires de crime
ayant une incroyable perception erronée de
la valeur du témoignage de témoins oculaires et nous
sommes élevés pour penser après des années à
regarder des émissions à ce sujet dans des films à
ce sujet et à y penser et à en
parler que si quelqu'un se tient
notre  est assis dans un box des jurés dans une salle d'audience
et dit que je l'ai vu, il l'a fait, il a gagné
que c'est une preuve irréfutable
et comment cette personne pourrait-elle avoir tort et
la personne qu'elle désigne doit
être coupable et le pourcentage de fois
que c'est défectueux et  les raisons pour lesquelles
il est défectueux m'ont vraiment vraiment
surpris
[Musique]
Je pense que le projet d'entreprise a
changé ma vie, bien sûr, mais
aussi pour beaucoup de gens quand j'ai
été arrêté pour la première fois, il n'y avait pas
de projet Innocence, vous savez là-bas  était
cette raison n'existait pas, je pense que la plupart des
gens fuient de gros problèmes comme
celui-ci impliquant des condamnations injustifiées
impliquant tous les éléments le tribunal la
loi et la force constitutionnelles et les témoins
également toutes les composantes émotionnelles, mais
pour ces personnes de courir vers elle et
de  dire que nous allons défendre ces gens
est incroyable